طيب هل فكرت في وجود فائده مهمه للرموز
التعبيريه التي نستخدمها في مواقع التواصل
عوضا عن بعض الكلمات والتعبيرات نحكي عن
الايموجيز طبعا هناك عدد كبير من الاطباء
اقترحوا بان تكون الايموجي كما نسميها
والوجوه هذه اساس للغه عالميه قائمه على
الايموجي التعبيري باتفاق مشترك لهذه
المعاني طبعا هذه الفقره الغريبه اقترحها
العالم بجامعه كاليفورنيا
عندما كان يصمم نظام قياس قائم على رموز
التعبيريه على مدار العامين الماضيين
واوضح انها يمكن ان تكون اداه مفيده
للمرضى الذين لا يستطيعون الكلام وفق ما
كتب في مجله الجمعيه الطبيه الامريكيه
وخاصه لمساعده مرضى السكته الدماغيه او
اولئك الذين ليستخدمون اجهزه التنفس
الصناعي في التعبير عن اعراضهم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات